it's a fight for working Americans of
both the president Trump secured in 2016
and now he's looking to regain their
support Trump turning up the heat on his
Democratic contenders in the
all-important battleground state of
Pennsylvania yesterday I'll have to hit
Pocahontas very hard again if she does
win but she's staging a little bit of a
comeback what a group Pocahontas and
sleepy Joe I don't think they give a
damn about western Pennsylvania you're
the ones who work hard pay your taxes
build your neighborhood now you finally
have a president of the United States
who is loyal to you
the DNC responding to President Trump's
attacks this morning it's clear that
Democrats stand on the side of workers I
think you see Democrats talking about
wanting to raise wages you talk about
skills trading time and time again we're
talking about how we're gonna fuel the
economy hole after poll shows that
voters are really sick of him tweeting
and and the attacks and I think that if
he continues that then Democrats will be
in a strong position
this comes as Joe Biden's frontrunner
status may be starting to slip a new
national poll shows Elizabeth Warren in
a virtual tie for the with the Vice
former vice president and in New
Hampshire a new poll actually has Bernie
Sanders beating Biden so Iowa and New
Hampshire they're not built-in
advantages for Joe Biden right the South
Carolina it's kind of got that wall of
support there you're looking at me as
though you were asking me a question I
was thinking should I ask Greg this
question and then I was thinking he's
gonna say why are you asking me this
question no but because I have a theory
that's when I was bragging yesterday we
talked about Trump's success with small
donors he's got like 65 percent it
reflects grassroots passion and the
average voter is passion for him who
exceeds him
Bernie his small donors are similar like
between 60 and 70% which says he's the
guy to galvanize the Trump opposition in
my opinion no one has his support or his
authenticity but you know who else has
60% plus donors Liz Warren
so Liz and Bernie are essentially the
same candidate which means when one
drops out it absorbs the other well
one's gonna have they're gonna have to
start attacking each other well no but
I think what's gonna happen is what the
one's gonna have to go away and they and
they join together cuz cuz like Bernie's
people aren't gonna go to Joe and Liz's
people aren't gonna go to Joe so you're
gonna end up with a plurality of maybe
40% for Joe or for Liz they get the
nomination so who wins wonderful common
sense politics you know what I think
it's from sitting next to you for so
long Dana I've absorbed it I like your
theory but isn't it true one Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders they're gonna
at some point someone's gonna have to
join the fight well but the fights been
going on and what you see is not really
between the two of them oh that well but
the fight is going on it doesn't benefit
either of them to attack the other right
because you don't want to alienate
people that you want to come to your
side but the fact is that Elizabeth
Warren is clearly the person with
momentum and this has been clear for a
long time and Bernie Sanders who's now
carpeting about even the liberal press
is the one who is falling and part of
this is as I said before it feels like
I've seen this movie before when it
comes to Bernie
I've seen a lot of the kind of rhetoric
I've seen a lot of the attacks and so
you know it doesn't have any freshness
Elizabeth Warren with all of her ideas
I've got a solution I got a plan and her
energy has just been something and right
now with all the bad news we've seen on
the stock market today the you know I
think a dial was like a 703 weeks that
the Dow is lost 7% thing yeah and I
think when you have you factor in that
there's going to be a higher awareness
of the nation's economy and its impact
suddenly Elizabeth Warren and all that
she said about consumer protections
reigning in Wall Street don't let the
big guys say they're too big to fail
it has new application to this moment
what about western Pennsylvania
President Trump was able to they went
there for a reason he needs Pennsylvania
to stay red and also remember in that
last debate Joe Biden said he would get
rid of fossil fuels in ten years yeah
really dumb comment from sleepy Joe the
American worker has shifted from the
Democratic Party to the Republican Party
under Trump for three reasons one
Trump's focus on trade immigration and
energy and the Democrats have
capitulated on all those things if you
think about
America first or made in America and the
attack on NAFTA and the attack on China
that kind of economic nationalism has
really galvanized wage growth and really
seen an explosion in manufacturing in
this country his focus on US Steel US
autos and even unions has peeled away
that support from the Democratic Party
and the Democrats would call it totally
flat-footed in 2016 and now they're
playing defense in their own Rust Belt
all on the border Trump has protected
the American worker from cheap labor
that drives those wages down and steals
American jobs and the Democrats have
decided to side with foreign workers and
against the American worker and the
American worker does not like that and
then thirdly just Trump's focus on
American energy independence American
energy dominance talking about
re-establishing drilling and
exploitation for natural gas and
re-emerging coal in West Virginia and
instead what the Democrats have done the
Democrats have said okay we're gonna get
rid of coal and oil and gas and our
first term as president and that would
just completely destroy the US economy
so you got to give Trump some credit but
you also have to blame the Democrats too
let me just quickly rebut this and say
you can't do it quickly I think in that
district in the midterms the Democrats
won Jessie and they won just like the
width of the healthcare and they won by
saying hey you know what we stand for
you American where it's just like today
Trump goes to that plant do you know
when when shale said they were gonna
build that plant 2012 when Barack Obama
you've seen jobs in that sector steel
gave up by 5,000 where they shedded
under Biden and Obama Emily to speak
thank you I just had a quick point about
actually where that's gel plant where
the president was talking that's
actually in a really unique part of the
country and stalwart Republicans like
Ronald Reagan in both bushes were never
able to carry that super heavily Pro
Union County until McCain in 2008
secured it for the GOP and and not
because he was really likable but
because the policies he was running
against were so liberal and since then
Republicans obviously have been winning
by increasing margins there but I think
Joe Biden
for anyone else is the only Democratic
candidate that actually has a chance of
carrying those counties surrounding
Pittsburgh because it harkens probably
pro-union Democratic heyday but all
right it's too loose we